rup
Paul who I don't really know like I know
the face and I know the name I don't
really know what that person does other
than pop up on TV and say outrageous
things every now and again rup Paul has
just come out and
said that that everyone needs to cool it
with the around drag queen Story
Hour listen if a drag queen wants to
read you a story at a library listen to
her
because knowledge is power and if
someone tries to restrict your access to
power they are trying to scare you so
listen to a drag queen we love you thank
you listen to a drag queen knowledge is
power really interesting point rup Paul
now do Bibles in schools what about that
if a teacher wants to read you a Bible
in a school you should let her write
right you should listen to oh no no no
we can't do that no no no that's
terrible that's unconstitutional that's
evil that's oppressive that's terrible
don't ever let anyone do that
ever if a conservative student group
wants to host a totally mainstream
right-wing public figure you should go
listen to that person right no no we
have to shut them down that's terrible
because knowledge is power that's the
one point that that guy made that's true
knowledge is power and the dissemination
of knowledge is power information is
power this term misinformation has
become very popular these days but it's
a silly term I'm not the first to
observe
it there's just
information there are information Wars
that go on and uh what sort of
information is allowed to get out there
what sort of information is publicly
encouraged how that information gets out
there what kind of information gets
Amplified that's going to determine the
Contours of the standards and Norms of
your Society it's going to it's going to
determine how people perceive the world
and how they behave and what kind of
country that you live in that's what
that's about what rup Paul and all the
rest of the the pro pro drag people are
saying is not we want Total Free Speech
they obviously don't look at the list
put out by
fire what they want is their subversive
false ugly Wicked voices to be heard and
to set the Contours of society and they
want to suppress voices that are
traditional Common Sense true good
beautiful any anything like that that
they've got to keep out this is
why a lot of this craziness on campus
began almost immediately after liberal
activists on the courts banned the Bible
in prayer from
schools because nature abor a vacuum so
once you once you take the truth and the
good and the good stuff and the kind of
information that built our whole
civilization when you take that out of
schools there's a a vacuum and what's
going to fill that is going to be less
good and less beautiful and less true
especially then when the schools uh
double down on all of it and create
incentives for more of it and special
protections for it and the popular
culture encourages it as well right now
go to TN
usa.com are you struggling with back
taxes or have unfiled returns this year
the IRS is escalating collections by
adding 20,000 new agents in these
challenging times your best defense is
to use tax Network USA with over 14
years of experience tax Network USA has
saved their clients over $1 billion in
back taxes they specialize in
negotiating with the IRS and aim to
reduce your debt significantly tax
Network USA doesn't just negotiate they
protect your assets from IRS seizures
and manage your yearly returns for
ongoing compliance importantly they're
licensed to help with all state tax
issues regardless of where you live in
the US seize control of your financial
future now don't let tax issues
overpower you you contact tax Network
USA for immediate relief and expert
guidance call 1800 245 6000 or visit TN
usa.com nsw turn to tax Network USA and
find your path to financial peace of
mind that is TN usa.com
slns hold on to your seats if you're
driving pullover this one's going to
shock you the president of an
lgbtq Pride organization in Canada has
been arrested for child sex
crimes stop the presses hat tip to Libs
of tikt for pointing this out uh the
guy's name is Shawn gravels he is an
outspoken LGBT activist head of a pride
organization in Canada arrested for not
not only for uh possessing and
distributing child pornography but for
sex crimes against children really
really awful heinous sort of
stuff it's always the ones you most
expect it's that's not totally fair it
is sometimes people that you don't
expect the the counter example I can
hear it now all the libs responding to
this clip that inevitably will be broken
up by Media Matters they'll say what
about the Catholic priests and there
there was a major sex scandal especially
at the turn of the Millennium uh among
Catholic priests that's
true now Catholics were not unique in
this regard that the the level of sexual
uh disorder and and criminality that
they found among Catholic priests it it
wasn't particular to that religion it's
true it's it's about the same rate as
every other religious group out there
it's actually considerably lower than
certain other religious groups
especially non-Christian religious
groups uh but it's
also much much lower than uh sex abuse
among Public School teachers much much
lower than Public School teachers it's
multiples higher than the Catholic
priests
but usually it's the ones you most
expect usually it's not the really nice
upstanding family guy who does what he's
supposed to do and leads an apparently
virtuous life usually it's like these
guys okay it's the guys who make their
whole identity weird sex stuff and who
run weird sex clubs and I guess my
question here
is why do we encourage this why do allow
this to happen why are there weird sex
organizations all over the West there
didn't used to be now there are and they
hold big parades in the middle of the
street and they are permitted to go to
public libraries and elementary schools
and put on weird sex performances
specifically targeted toward kids often
involving actual child molesters that
have been convicted and have been widely
reported on why why do we tolerate this
the first amendment I don't think the
founding fathers were into this stuff
this this would not have been tolerated
until recent decades this has no bearing
on the First Amendment or the American
tradition why to what
end because some pervert wants to do it
I why I don't care what Shawn grael
wants to do about anything he's very
deviant and disordered and he he has no
right to do any of this stuff why do why
do we encourage it what's what's good
about it what good is to be gained from
it not very much we don't think in those
terms though anymore what's good like
basic stuff you know polities exist uh
to do more good stuff and less bad stuff
and so people can live a good life in a
flourishing Community how about we start
thinking that way because otherwise the
way that our political communities are
going to be ordered is when bad people
who like to do bad things go meet up and
plot out how to control the world and
invite actual witches to guide them in
doing that man what a great clip that
was now hold
up ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel and we
will catch you next time